march is colorectal cancer awareness
month and rocky spoke to a southwest
medical doctor to learn more here's
their conversation
of course we've got a lot to talk about
i know you are a gastroenterologist
please define that for everybody what do
you do so i
am a stomach and colon doctor basically
i deal with intestinal diseases
like ulcers uh colon cancers
um you know anything that has to do with
the gi tract
march is colorectal cancer awareness
month so this is a great time to
educate everybody on the statistics
right
correct colorectal cancer is the third
most common diagnosed cancer
in the united states and 147 000 people
can be diagnosed with cancer in one year
and 50
53 000 people can die of colorectal
cancer
every year so it's definitely
a cancer that that can be prevented
and that's what we're here to do
absolutely prevention is key here so
what should people
look for you know when they're when
they're trying to self-diagnose
mainly people should look for
common symptoms would be bleeding so
blood in your stool
or blood in the toilet bowl change in
your bowel habits if they become thinner
or smaller
or you start having diarrhea abdominal
pain
weight loss that's unexplained so
colonoscopy is what we use
to prevent colon cancer and it's a
procedure that i do
that's done as an outpatient to look for
either polyps
which are lesions in the colon that can
turn into cancer if not removed
or actual colon cancer so if i see a
polyp i would remove it and
prevent that person from getting colon
cancer other screening tests would be
uh two stool tests that we have
currently one is the fit test
uh which is done at home and it looks
for blood in the stool microscopic blood
meaning blood that you might not be able
to
see um and so that's one of the tests
and then the most recent test that we
have is
called the cola guard test which is
actually a stool test that looks for
cancer or pre-cancerous cells
in the stool which can be seen
with large polyps or actual colon cancer
so if these tests are positive then you
would want to
proceed with the colonoscopy colon
cancer is very preventable
with colonoscopy or the other screening
modalities everyone over the age of
50 and actually recently has been
lowered to 45
up to 75 to 80 should be
screened regularly for colon cancer
because that's the only way we're going
to prevent it well how often should
people get a colonoscopy
um so it depends um upon their family
history
um and if they've had polyps in the past
um usually it's every 10 years for the
normal population
but can be up to five years if you have
a family history of colon cancer
or have a history of polyps southwest
medical has several locations across
southern nevada
for more information call 702-877-5199
or visit smalv.com
las vegas now